Hey remember when Rogue One trailers came out on the Internet went "OOOOOOOOOOOH
We figured out who Rey's mom is!" Do we have any updates on that?
Yeah, it might be time to rethink that one.
*Film Theory theme plays*
Hello Internet
welcome to Film Theory
The show that knows the chances of one of my Star Wars theories
successfully navigating successfully navigating the asteroid field of the internet are
3,720 to 1 but you know what
I just can't help myself
You know loyal theorists, it takes a big man to admit when he's wrong and, uh,
Yeah, I've been kinda wrong once or twice when it comes to Star Wars.
Evil Luke in Force Awakens? STEEEERIKE ONE!
Rogue One squadron turning into the Knights of Ren?
Yeah, that was a BIG strike two (Although that one should have been right).
A wiser man might have learned his lesson by now but if I was really that wise I probably wouldn't own the prequels on
Blu-ray!
Don't you judge me it's for the sake of completeness
anyway with Star Wars season just around the corner and the recent release of The Last Jedi's official trailer, I am in full
Star Wars hype mode. I'm happier than a porgin
Whatever porgs enjoy I don't know it's just a new creature designed to sell toys a porg plush at a target retailer near you
anyway i recently rewatched the force awakens and after i breathed my sigh of relief that no
gungans
had found their way into it cuz you never can tell with these movies i was struck by how many questions it leaves open who
is Snoke? Why did the first order build a giant death star with essentially the same weakness as the original death star
what is that insta bread that rey makes for dinner and where can i get some because it looks delicious but seriously the biggest
Question has to be rey
herself who the heck is this girl it's a question the internet latched on to in the aftermath of this movie and it's one that
We all know is going to be answered by the last jedi so if i'm gonna put my theory hat into the ring i better
Do it now who are raised parents the internet has explored this one
To its fullest i think if i look hard enough i could probably find someone who claims that she's the daughter of
C-3po, and a jawa but today i'm gonna prove, to you which is the correct choice in fact i am, so
confident in this theory that i'm gonna say spoiler alert right here yeah
spoiler alert for a movie that has not been released yet i don't necessarily
Believe all my theories but today i think i have this one nail and i think by the end of this episode you're gonna agree
with
Me too so make sure you stay through the whole episode then let me know at the end in the comments if you think that
i got it now dust off your sensible sweaters and dna test kits ladies and gentlemen
matt povich is here to tell some of these dudes that you are not
To begin let's establish the details we know about rey that'll help us reach our?
conclusion one she was left on jakku as a small girl and hasn't seen her family since - she's a talented pilot
even a natural and three she speaks with a british
Accent despite receiving no training that we know of anyway she's able to use a lightsaber and jedi mind-trick a stormtrooper
suggesting that she is four
incredibly sensitive to the force five luke's lightsaber calls were in maz kanata's castle
And six let's remember that classic george lucas quote that the star wars story is quote like poetry?
it rhymes so we need a lineage that not only fits the
characteristics we know about rey but also the thematic elements of the saga in general ok with our main criteria established
let's make a case for bachelor number one from what i can tell the internet's current and bedding favourite luke
skywalker a lot of parallels here are pretty obvious
ray
And luke both grew up on desert planets raised by people other than their parents they both join up with han solo and then battle
against a family member remember
Kylo ren would be raised cousin if she's luke's daughter who offers to teach them in the ways of the dark side so you definitely
have a big checkmark in that whole rhyming story
category then you have the fact that luke's lightsaber calls to rage
seeming to suggest a family bond or shared unity know even though ray and luke don't talk to each other at the end of the
Force awakens we do get some interesting tidbits from the screenplay quote he looks at rey
kindness in his eyes but there's something tortured - he doesn't need to ask her who she is or what she's doing there his
look says it all
end quote i know the force is strong with luke and all but some girl just finds him while he's brooding on a cliff and
he doesn't need to ask her who she is that probably means he
recognizes her which he would if she were his long-lost daughter this is also supported by the crucial line used in trailers for force awakens
Force is strong in my family my father has it, i have it, my sister has it and have that power too
It definitely seems like this is something luke would be saying to rey and if that's the case he would be
implicitly looping rey into his family as yet another
Strong force user we even get a few hints from outside the movies had a panel discussion with the cast of the force awakens mark
hamill teased the relationship by saying i see my dau- i mean my colleague
daisy no it's
Absolutely possible that grampy skywalker is just trolling the audience but there is such a thing as hiding in plain sight but maybe the best
clue
we get comes from kathleen kennedy
president of lucasfilm who gave an interview to the costco
connection in october 2015 in which she stated quote the saga films by what she means the original trilogy the prequels and now the new
trilogy focus on the skywalker family saga end quote now while i'm generally skeptical of the things i read in
newspapers printed by stores that sell 30 pound buckets of mayonnaise this is pretty hard to ignore
if we're saying that episode 7 8 & 9 are about the
Skywalker's and that the story rhymes it makes plenty of sense that rey would take the torch from luke as
His daughter but as the internet's pointed out this is far from the only possible explanation if you want to talk about
force-sensitive loners living on desert planets well then meet bachelor number 2
obi-wan kenobi that
lightsaber that called to rey let's not forget that before it was luke's it was obi wan's and when rey has her force vision we
Hear the voices of both alec guinness and you and mcgregor the two actors who've played obi-wan
also rey speaks with a british accent if she's a
Skywalker it's hard to say where that would have come from if she's descended from the kenobi's well no explanation necessary
and then when it comes to pure jedi style rey closes her eyes when she's in a lightsaber duel just like
obi-wan did she even uses obi wan's famous jedi mind-trick as one of her first
realizations of her powers true this would mean that rey isn't exactly part of the skywalker saga that kathleen kennedy mentioned but how
interesting would it be for the series to go from a kenobi training a skywalker to a
skywalker then training a kenobi certainly fits that hold rhyme test that george lucas
Mentioned alright alright it's time to get serious it's not my job here to hand out gold stars and praise everyone's theories it's my job
To get
one problem with rey being luke's daughter or obi wan's granddaughter is that it's against jedi rules in the doctrine of the jedi order
teaching number four is that jedi are wary of attachments both material and
personal a lot of the other quote unquote clues that we just covered can be explained away pretty easily as well the british
accent thing maybe ray just picked that up from boone carr plot the guy she was just left with when she was a small child
I mean just listen to him what you brought me today is worth one
quarter portion
and sure it's true that luke's lightsaber
called turay and that obi wan's voice is heard during her force vision but she also sees darth vader and
here's yoda if anything she's being called by the
force not a
specific family member so now let's consider a quote from daisy ridley herself after the force awakens had opened timeout london asked her about her
character's backstory
She answered by saying quote i thought a lot was answered in the force awakens?
then after the screening i went for a drink with my agent and everyone and we were chatting away and i realized that oh in
Their minds it's not answered at all consider this if daisy ridley thought a lot had been answered in episode 7 then we're probably
looking for more than just a voice in a dream or a knowing look on a cliffside
so i rewatched the movie and here's a line that's stuck with me kylo ren has just captured rey and is keeping her captive after
mentioning that he doesn't know what happened to her friends he says with what sounds like genuine surprise you still want to kill me
still as in wanted to kill you before
Kylo ren and rey just met but he seems to know who she is based on his
reaction to first hearing about her the two were accompanied by a girl
what girl how would he know about this random desert planet girl and how powerful she is unless they had shared a common past does
Kylo ren know rae already because she's his sister yes, han solo you are the father
wow, he did not take that well at all but seriously all the pieces fit look at everything that we've covered today if she's the
daughter of leia that's where her force powers are coming from that means that she's luke's niece and that lightsaber is still a family heirloom
that would be calling out to her we never get a good explanation as
To why rey was stashed away on Jakku but looked back at Luke's quote from the last jedi trailer I've seen this raw strength
Only once before it didn't scare me enough then it does now
In the middle of it we see his hand emerge from under some burning rubble followed by an image of what we can assume as
the jedi temple that kylo ren destroys it's certainly possible that the kind of raw strength luke saw before and didn't fear was
kylos if han and leia realized that her older brother was suddenly becoming very powerful and very
evil they might want to get her away from his influence ie
hiding her out on jakku speaking of trailer moments that line from the force awakens trailer about the force being strong in luke's family still
applies here it's just now he's saying it to his niece instead of his daughter the british accent could come from unkar plots or
maybe just from her mother's oddly inconsistent british tones in episode four the more you tighten your grip talk
of star systems will slip through your fingers episode seven eight-nine can still continue the skywalker saga as
kathleen kennedy put it by following rey and the new trilogy can still rhyme with the original to force using
siblings who were separated as children become
Reunited with one having to save the other the one who lived on an isolated desert planet is mentored by an old jedi
who just so happens to tweet pictures of himself on her back in a clear allusion to the yoda luke
relationship from the empire strikes back oh yeah and that whole natural pilot thing had to have gotten something from her father
yeah
See that is all six of our criteria?
covered and there is still more if you are
Still not convinced don't worry cuz i saved the best for last here are three deep dive pieces of evidence that are gonna sell you
on this theory number one in one of the
we're mark hamill tease the audience about rey being his daughter he mentioned that at the initial table read of the force awakens
seating was assigned and that rather than being seated next to him daisy ridley was in between
harrison ford and carrie fisher now for those of you who don't know
Table reads are structured to seat you closest to the people your character shares the closest or most important
Relationships with she shares a lot of scenes with han solo so sitting next to harrison ford makes sense but leia not
So much and especially
Squeezing her in between the two of them is awfully strange if she's not in some way related
to them point number two actress billie lourd who plays the bit role of lieutenant conics in the force awakens
originally auditioned for the role of rey why is that fishy because billie lourd happens to be carrie fisher's
real-life daughter if you're looking to establish a family resemblance
Casting mother and daughter as mother and daughter ought to do it and here's the biggest
number three the meme tastic hug that leia gives ray after han is killed leia walks right past
chewbacca who she's known for decades and who was hans
Partner for longer than that instead going straight to comforting brave a girl she would have never met before
There's a reason why the internet ripped into this moment it's insane it's
stupid it's silly until you consider that leia might be ray's mother and looking at the screenplay gives us even greater cause for suspicion
quote the two women move for each other and leia takes a Rey's face in her hands despite her heartbreak she's grateful
She embraces rey a mother's embrace
Huh!
interesting choice of words there but hey that's just a theory a film theory and
May, the force be with you
these are not the droids you're looking for
This is the subscribe button you were looking for this is the subscribe button you are planning on clicking because with the star wars tv
show
Coming out yeah that's news if you haven't heard that one you'll want to make sure you're up to date on all the latest
Theories about the universe so click it it's not a trap